dans ses cuisines dix mille repas sont
préparés chaque jour pour les enfants du
sud
depuis des années les locaux sont les
mêmes les salariés aussi une centaine
mais ils ont travaillé pour trois
sociétés différentes
la datex écarté en 2013 puis servi chez
f et enfin la sauge s depuis 2010 est
depuis l'éviction de la datex les
procédures judiciaires se multiplient et
les salariés sont excédés de craindre
pour leur avenir
ce feuilleton il nous perturber
moralement le personnel est saturé on en
a assez des différents combats
judiciaires
nous avons besoin d'un stabilise
stabilité nous avons besoin de continuer
dans cette direction sommes avec la
sagesse au sens très bien à maintes
reprises les tribunaux ont donné raison
à la datex mettant d'abord fin la
délégation de service chef puis menace
aujourd'hui la sauge est ce une
instabilité qui entravent les projets
personnels autant que les plans de
carrière personnelle et un souffle
secousse a aidé les gens vivent ça très
mal
c'est quelque chose que nous vivons très
mal parce que à chaque fois chaque fin
d'année à chaque année et a toujours
cette histoire de justice l'épée de
damoclès sur les sociétés on peut pas
négocier quand même comme on veut avec
nous
nous dit jah vous avez quand même des
salaires quand même qu'ils aient texte
très très très bas on n'a pas pu pouvoir
négocier parce qu'à chaque fois il y
avait cette histoire de justice si
l'attribution des marchés publics et si
facilement contestable en justice les
salariés eux mettent en avant leur
sérieux et leur savoir faire
je suis pas inquiet par rapport à ce que
nous devons faire comme métier à savoir
la restauration faire à manger pour les
enfants nous sommes des professionnels
qui sont installés depuis plus de 20 ans
et aujourd'hui nous maîtrisons quand
même notre notre métier est ce que nous
demandons c'est de la sérénité auprès de
nos dirigeants de ceux qui contrôlent un
petit peu tout tout ce petit manche est
là qu il prenne en considération notre
métier que nous avons envie de
travailler sereinement la sagesse doit
modifier ses statuts qui ne permettait
pas l'attribution d'un marché de
restauration l'espace sud aurait rassuré
les salariés sur la continuité de leur
nouvelle entreprise mais clairement
aujourd'hui le feuilleton n'est pas
terminé